so as just mentioned I'm a designer a UX
designer I work at no Jitsu a company
which does cloud orchestration software
but and now I also organize JavaScript
meetups in Poland in Krakow and I also
helped run the number mattress nodejs
evangelism company sort of kinda so to
help with jQuery right
I mean jQuery sucks are you a real
programmer or jQuery programmer right am
i right
are you agreeing with me we're Chris
with me okay no like are you insane man
okay let me tell you a story I'm a
designer I'm not a JavaScript developer
which is kind of weird because I met Jay
as confroy so when I started designing
which out when I started designing I
also started thinking okay so I should
be able to code my designs right I think
that every designers come to this
conclusion right so I started coding I
learned Fernan a CSS HTML and then I
started working at new Jitsu
so no Jitsu is a really cool company and
they're full of really good nodejs
developers contributing to core really
awesome people so I thought hmm maybe I
should learn how to do JavaScript right
because it doesn't make sense to write
on so I started programming and this
made me think about the tools that I'm
using on my daily basis because if you
are a designer usual you are using
Photoshop that's natural
Photoshop is the base for your work on
the other hand Photoshop is really a
mysterious black box we have no idea how
it works sometimes it crashes is doing
really really really weird things and
you don't necessarily know why it's
happening you just get this weird
message or spinning
wheel whoops it's crashed hmm okay let
me start and start working again so we
cannot be back Photoshop errors right so
it's a black box on the other hand the
web is not a black box the nature of the
web says that and the software itself
it's very different it's open and we
have this amazing thing the ability to
view the source which is a very very
very powerful tool it was very hard a
few years ago when we had no github it
was very hard to check how it works and
learn from code but then there was
github and now we are able to read the
code which is so awesome we can learn a
lot so this makes me think about the
root cause of this problem is jQuery
crappy our other libraries crappy so it
all comes down to two kinds of people
operators and engineers operator is a
person who knows how to use a tool ok so
I can take a toaster and make a toast
like everyone can do that it's so easy
but do I know how it works
not necessarily I just know how to use
it I just know how to make a toast an
engineer knows how the thing works from
the ground up so he can modify you can
adjust it for their knees he has full
awareness of the code so we should aim
towards being engineers right
everyone is saying read the [ __ ]
manual right we all know this expression
but it leads us to a question which is
to be actually ritika who read jQuery
code base that's actually surprising but
still is like 10 percent or 20 maybe how
many of you reads the code base of every
library you are using nice it's like 10
people and it's probably like hundreds
in the room or more
so for me read the [ __ ] code is the
new read the [ __ ] manual it's kind of
a generalization but the Internet is
giving us this opportunity to [ __ ]
about things right usually you go in
like oh my god this website is so awful
or the software I had this terrible
experience with that product so it gives
this freedom for people to complain not
necessarily while being anonymous you
can just sign in and [ __ ] about it on
Twitter Facebook whatever but mostly
it's about people being really lazy
because as we've seen ten people said
that they're actually reading the code
basement they are using library so we
are kind of lazy we don't care about
checking the code we're using so
basically we're using a tool without
knowing how it works and how we are in
position to judge this software or the
library we don't necessarily know how it
works
so is it hype because it's a very hype
opinion jQuery sucks everyone knows that
right so the human factor makes it worse
so we established that is really
valuable to read the code what are the
benefits of it so libraries are trying
to solve a lot of problems a very broad
spectrum usually which naturally affects
the level of complexity so you're not
actually sure how much complexity are
willing to take on you when you're
choosing a library because you're not
reading the code you're just like ah
okay I have this client and he wanted
this fancy date picker so I found this
cool library which is doing fancy date
pickers so we just use it and whatever
it works it's nice and fancy but this is
this really affects the complexity
you're willing to deal with and this is
also a problem of cognitive load
which is translated to the difficult
difficulty associated with the
understanding of a certain content
concept so should libraries really be
that complex should they solve that many
issues or should they be more
specialized for me kind of the idea of
the library is that is addressing one
issue or maybe a few small issues it's
not like oh let's just put Ajax in
jQuery because Jake Ajax is so cool so
let's put it there but why on the other
hand so maybe they should not follow
that all-in-one concept on the other
hand while reading the code of the
library we can see some good patterns
usually libraries are written by good
developers like powers of course and we
can notice good patterns we can benefit
from that we can learn because not all
of us are really great programmers right
on the other hand some parts may be
really really over engineered may be
very complicated
unnecessarily and we all strive for
simplicity the solution we may take is
to choose a micro framework over a
library because I've said the library is
usually huge its kind of framework ish
and micro framework has usually modular
approach it's very lightweight is
addressing a specific issue for example
if you go to micro J's what tile you
have this all really tiny libraries
which will work great for my well
they're easy to understand because the
code base is smaller on the other hand
libraries have some benefits to their
well tested they have better cross
browser compatibility they have
backtracking software more documentation
sometimes they are more reliable for
production so do not give this talk only
inspirational there's some examples I
said to halogen which
a query but jQuery is good for central
and thanks of course like every library
is and when is used in a good way by
someone who is aware of the fact that
what he's doing with the software he has
- that's a really common comparison to
choose jQuery and CSS because jQuery is
doing all the weird things they're
mapping CSS selectors so you can use
selectors either in CSS or of jQuery
that's kind of weird and may sound
insane right so jQuery has a lot of
stuff which is actually very easily
achievable by pure CSS but also it has a
lot of stuff which cannot be achieved in
CSS for example the parent selector it's
not available in CSS it is specified in
a working draft but on the other hand
it's raising really serious performance
issues because all elements on your
website need to be loaded and then the
meshing grill needs to be evaluated for
a child within the element so if you
have three paragraphs in one element and
one diff it needs to go three times so
it's like a really really severe
performance issue on the other hand as
I've said you have a lot of things you
can achieve both with jQuery and CSS so
which way to choose you can use the
animate function oricon is CSS
animations before in the past you
weren't able to do that because there
was no CSS animation but now we have all
this crazy html5 CSS free hype and
amazing tools and if talking about
animation we have over 80% of support
which is kind of foreign oil but it's
achievable through CSS so sometimes when
you think about the solutions you want
to choose CSS is the way to go but why
because it has native execution so it's
being rendered directly in the browser
the processor is written in C++ so it's
faster
javascript which needs to be interpreted
you can have hardware acceleration for
some people CSS is way more
straightforward the JavaScript like for
example imagine me I'm a designer so
kind of CSS is more appealing than
JavaScript I can look at JavaScript like
a year ago
and I'm like oh not understand I don't
know what's happening in here
but as I've said not everything is
possible with in-plane CSS like for
example you can append content with same
content and append some text but on the
other hand it's very it's very difficult
also as I've said it may be potentially
easier for designers on the other hand
if you're doing all this crazy
animations transformations into thing
about the degradation issue not all of
the browser's are supporting the thing
you're trying to do but let's shift from
jQuery problem to a different library
because I think that the idea behind
this talk is more it can be targeted to
where every library so you know Express
when I was expressed yeah okay so
Express is good but do you know how it
works that's a really really basic
example this is like native No
and you can shoot the same thing with
express nice right but it's usually
easier and better to read native code so
what's wrong with Express well nothing
is wrong with Express if you think about
the solution and think you are trying to
achieve because if you try to install
Express you will see all the dis
dependencies and you have all these
different module outers
so you need to think of the modulus
maintained if it's good there are all
these considerations you need to think
about it so what's the better approach
first of all modularity so separating
separation of concerns separating the
presentation layer phonetic separating
functionalities to make them work
together but on the other hand managing
their independent nature also clarity
making the code readable to all
simplification but now not of the course
of understanding considering distributed
teamwork also a lot of us are working
for startups we are working on
distributed teams so having really clear
cut is very important and especially
when you are working on our fizzers
project you want people to understand
your code it's not only about commenting
it's also about the readability
another thing is composition so we said
it's really important to separate logic
from layout but it's also very important
to connect these things in a really good
way because libraries usually are
designed to work on their own there are
not necessarily designed to work with
each other because as a library after
how you can think that ok I should work
with that and that and that different
library you're not thinking about it
you're usually thinking yeah just I just
made this library this is this was
solved this issue and it should just
work that's all so you should have write
conflicts like jQuery does you can use
not no conflict function to avoid
problems with other libraries a really
good example of designing for connection
is piping in Unix
so we are standing Center are just an
are in by piping so now of course the
hello will be copied to your clipboard
another thing is instrumentation
simplifying debugging so you can either
do the thing on the left but you can
also do the longer take the longer
solution but why well you probably want
to you probably would like to check your
code after you deploy to production but
you don't want necessarily to have this
code then the production right so you
can either enable debugging or not you
should also avoid surprising people
people don't like surprises
so don over engineer or or create new
path me work patterns if there are
already patterns established for that
and this is really really a good example
taken from node for a really really good
pattern this is a really everyone knows
that if you're doing note you know that
you need to return error first it's
really straightforward so why you should
invent your own solution if there's
already a solution you should optimize
the speed of how you are coding and how
you are reading so bill and ship fast
prototype before polishing and be
diverse about the solutions you are
chilling there is no single valid and
best approach to solving your issue you
need to explore research the tools that
are available and choose the best one
for your job maybe it's Drake word maybe
its depth oh maybe it's something else
maybe you should write your own tool
because that's the way to go for you
and there's a really dangerous and false
assumption that you shouldn't be writing
your own code because you are
reinventing the wheel why doing that
and the last thing is extensibility so
thinking about progressive enhancement
you should be using features which are
available now they are well tested you
need to keep in mind the current support
but on the other hand into account the
fact that the future might be here
faster than FN so maybe you should
consider graceful degradation in some
browsers maybe you shouldn't be thinking
about about that it won't work and some
browser that's all about the
specification for the project you have
but you need to think about the status
coming in so it all comes down to not
disapprove about the solutions you are
using you're not necessarily been using
not don't disapper solutions because
because you don't know them that's what
people do right you say - how will
jQuery and you were like yeah but like
20 people just said that they read the
codebase so how you are basing your
opinion is it the hype opinion you are
taking or do you actually have an
argument in here you need to explore the
options you need to read the code you
need to know the tools you are using and
just be a better programmer thank you
one and one more thing before we go to
questions please I don't know if Tiffany
is here is she here no doesn't matter
but I will really like to thank you for
the work you are doing for encouraging
people to speak it's a really great
thing we are doing it's not about only
about female speakers but speakers in
general it's really we are awesome is an
best idea of seeing and whoever here
wants to speak to go see if any or talk
to me and yeah let's make it awesome and
let's make more people speak about
JavaScript that's all